all right so this is the perfect your
LinkedIn profile workshop today is 11:00
5:18 its Monday thank you all for
joining us at the beginning of a what
I'm sure is a busy week for you all and
taking some time out of your day to work
work on this together my name is Martin
I'm a career advisor here at Udacity and
I'm also a Content marketer you might
see some of the videos that we've been
creating for the careers team popping up
on LinkedIn lately especially if you're
on they're trying to go my entire goals
and get noticed in their field and so
that's a lot of what we're gonna be
talking about today how to actually
create a LinkedIn profile that not only
gets you found in search but helps you
attract and engage the people that you
want to be connecting with in your field
so you can actually make that next
career move or advance in your job or
whatever it is you're trying to
accomplish
so I'd love to do a little pulse check
here and see from the 121 participants
we have on our call how are you feeling
about your your profile right now on a
scale from one to five five being great
one being not so strong will get a good
pulse and a good sense of of what we
need to be covering based off this poll
all right can everyone see the poll in
my shared screen or is it only sharing
my desktop
everyone can see the pole wonderful 80%
of you have voted so we're going to give
a little bit of time here for you to
vote
you
Karin will end and publish it
I'm just a bit all right
great we're all viewing the full results
here so we've got about 19% of you
feeling not very strong about your
profiles about 16% of you feeling that
strong a little bit a little bit more
confident we got 39% of you the majority
of you just feeling okay about your
profiles 23% feeling good all right we
got some positive optimistic and we got
4% feeling great but I'm sure they still
want to learn a few tips and tricks to
really round out the edges so thank you
so much everyone for participating in
the poll today it looks like we've got
the majority of you feeling okay about
your profile you you've got it in a good
spot but you maybe don't feel like it's
tailored as specifically to what you're
hoping to accomplish in your career
goals so that's what we'll be talking
about today not only why you need it but
how to make it as as focus as possible
so that you can achieve what you want to
achieve
all right oh stop sharing clothes great
so I'll jump into the agenda here today
we're gonna start by going through the
basics the basics of LinkedIn why you
need to be on LinkedIn and what you need
on your profile not only just from a
general sense but also some of the
statistics behind it so you really know
why it's important to be here we're
gonna then jump into our live feedback
we've actually got two alumni one is
driving so we're gonna go through to
alumni profiles and we're gonna really
analyze their profiles and their career
goals to figure out you know they might
have they might be in good shape but how
do we make it even better or they might
be you know really hoping to maybe even
do an overhaul we'll see when we get
into it and so you'll get to see a live
critique of how to make your profile as
strong as possible the basics here of
what we're trying to take away from this
live feedback is what can you do when
you're looking at your profile what is
the perspective you can take to make
sure you're making it as strong as
possible and then we'll open it up to
everyone we've got about 130 people on
this call so I'm hoping some of you will
be courageous and and share your your
Linkedin URL and let us pull up your
profile and maybe take a look at your
summary or take a look at your
experience or take a look at your
education and start giving some really
quick tips that will engage the whole
group and not just have us be talking at
you but it may get a little bit more
interactive and then finally we're gonna
touch on how current students can submit
their project and get credit as well as
get an expert to review their profile
and that is a requirement of your
program so it's gonna be really great to
just kind of go through that and make
sure that you're able to accomplish that
piece of your program and also get that
feedback and make your profile look as
amazing as possible
alright let's start with the basics why
do you need to be on LinkedIn well I
know in the poll we didn't give you an
option for I don't have a LinkedIn
because the very baseline of anyone
who's in the job market at all is to
just have a basic profile back in the
day we actually did this really big test
to see what made the biggest difference
in someone's profile was at a great
summary was it a great skill section was
it a lot of recommendations and the main
thing that separated people who are
successful in their career roles and not
successful in their career goals was
just having a LinkedIn in general
because it's the first place that that
recruiters and potential employers are
going to go to figure out who you are
see your pictures to your experience and
make that connection to bringing you
with so here's a few stats to toss at
you to get you your wheels turning 260
million people are active on Linkedin 61
million are senior level influencers
which means if you're in if you're on
the LinkedIn platform there is just a
huge huge huge opportunity to connect
with senior level influencers forty
million are in decision-making positions
so if you're sitting there applying to
job boards and you're not getting much
activity interaction and feedback
positive engagement through those job
boards which honestly most people don't
get a lot of great feedback from job
boards LinkedIn is the place to go
because you can actually connect with
the real people who make the decisions
there's 26 million companies with 15
million active jobs and more than 90
percent of recruiters use LinkedIn
regularly basically is the largest
social network for your career and so we
want to be on there and we want to look
good on there and we want to be focused
on what our goals are and now now that
we know that we need to be there what do
you actually need to have on it LinkedIn
has this great little marker on their
profile that says how complete is your
profile and of course we want to get to
a hundred percent but you know there's a
lot of different sections on your
profile
to fill out so what is necessary and
what's not on your profile well here's a
few stats to think about if you have a
professional headshot you get 17 times
more views than someone who doesn't and
so if you take a look at your profile
you've just got that I know it's not an
egg it's not Twitter but if you've just
got a missing picture that is going to
be not only not opening up opportunities
for you but actually hurting your
opportunities so you need to make sure
you get a good photo on your profile
number two you want to make sure that
your education is on them so we're all
learning new things we're all indie
students and grads so you want to make
sure that it's updated with your most
recent education those folks who have
their education on there 17 more 17
times more likely to show up in search
and the reason for that is because
Google and LinkedIn are constantly
crawling your profile to search for
keywords and a lot of what you study
applies to your keywords so you're gonna
just show up and search much more often
location a lot of times recruiters and
hiring managers they do location-based
searches they they're not just saying I
made developer and they just open it up
to the world they're saying I need
someone who's local within this radius
or outside the city and so if you have a
location you'll be 23 times more likely
to show up and you know this brings up a
lot of questions what if you want to
work remote what if you're moving cities
we can get into that today typically you
want to put the location of where you
want to be down but just make sure
you've got a location there because
that'll help people find you you want to
have a great summary that speaks to your
skills and your interest your motivation
basically an elevator pitch so the
summary is probably the most ambiguous
piece of the LinkedIn profile and
something that will be different
depending on your background your skills
your goals and everyone would be
slightly different some people would be
funnier some people would be more
serious and people have a lot of stats
it'll it's not a one-size-fits-all thing
but you want to be pitching yourself in
that summary that's the first thing
people are going to read then you're
gonna want to have a great headline and
key word and
this this is kind of an interesting one
people struggle here too you want to put
the job title you wish you had
because here's how a recruiter or a
hiring manager is going to look they're
gonna sit down they're gonna type in the
job title but looking for the city that
they're looking in and hit enter and if
you don't have that job title in your
headline and that's City in your profile
you're not going to show up in that
search so we don't want to have
something like job seeking or seeking
new opportunities because no one ever
types that in when they're searching for
candidates so we'll get into that a
little bit more and then activity
activity is a big one LinkedIn has not
only been a great place to sort of store
all of your career history and and be a
digital spot for your resume to sit it's
an interactive platform so the more
you're interacting the more you're
popping up in people's feeds and the
more people can see your face the more
they know who you are and that's the
whole point of social media is from a
marketing standpoint visibility if you
never saw a Nike ad Nike would
eventually disappear and be replaced by
other people that are being a little bit
more in you know out in the public and
being seen so Nike has to continue
putting their name in front of you so
you don't forget who they are
same with us when we're doing the job
search we have to continue showing up
putting our face out there and making
sure people remember not only that we
exist but we are here to solve their
problems all right so there's a real
quick jump in and now we're gonna jump
into that live feedback we've got
Shannon and Dean and I know Ellen's
driving so we're gonna let her hang back
and not multitask too dangerously but
Shannon and Dean I love Shannon for you
to unmute first and introduce yourself
and then Dean we'll have you do the same
hey everyone like I said I'm Shannon I
am based in Baltimore Maryland and
currently I'm actually an email
developer actually majored in graphic
design did a lot of sort of learn code
mostly self-taught partially like boo
Kant or nanodegree type courses online
and my career goals are to move into
more of a front-end developer front-end
engineer temporals I recently graduate
from the grow with Google mobile web
specialist nanodegree about a week ago
I'm really excited and my next steps are
to learn more JavaScript and Python so
I'm looking for a role that would sort
of encompass some of that we learned in
the nanodegree that is awesome
all right and then Dean if you can jump
on introduce yourself as well my name is
Dean race engineer about 20 years in
industry working with us yeah definitely
US government about two years ago
decided want to refresh my refresh and
renew my skills public career I left
work and took on a machine learning data
science bootcamp and afterwards I was
looking to continue to learn looking for
online courses and I found that Udacity
self-driving car nanotubes that just
came out I just recently graduated from
that took me while different things
happen in life kind of put me a put a
delay on my progress and now that I'm
finished in nano degree I'm getting
prepared to reenter the Jacke job force
trying to transition from aerospace
engineers into sort of gear qual Ptolemy
engineers wonderful all right and
actually Ellen has is is no longer
driving so she is gonna be joining us as
well and be taking a look at her profile
so Ellen if you would like to introduce
yourself and just jump on the call here
daddy hey there hello everybody it's
morning so now I'm a steward PhD
students but I'm a plant trying to
withdraw my study in two weeks after I
join the PhD study I found I am engineer
not a scientist now a few days ago I
take a part-time job I'll ask the
developer I spent one month actually
it's a part-time job is then it cost me
20 hours per week to do our app yes
that's the internship job already done
so I'm looking I'm looking for an iOS
developer job but I'm learning I'm more
interested to do a date to sign stuff
later engineer job here look looking for
a job iOS developer and a data analyst
awesome yes will dig into your profile
in just a bit but thank you so much for
jumping on and introducing yourselves
Shannon Dean and Ellen this is gonna be
a great conversation today we're gonna
go into all your profiles and we'll try
to be quick with it but would also try
and be detailed so I feel free to feel
free to bring up any big questions that
are on your mind and and we'll be
digging in all right so we're gonna
start with Shannon and I've got your
LinkedIn pulled up right here but
we jump in there LinkedIn you are a
self-taught developer you work as an
email developer right now and your
background is an art and design a couple
of questions I have for you and this is
something for everyone to think about
who's on the call but before you go in
and start updating things right the
tactics of LinkedIn this is you know
basics marketing strategy 101 before you
go out and start working on your tactics
you want to make sure you have the right
strategy otherwise we're just gonna be
constantly changing things on your
profile every single week that you think
of something new so Shannon a couple of
questions for you before we jump in
where are you looking for a job like
location wise City what title are you
most interested in and what industry
interests you the most those are really
good questions as far as location wise
I'm based in Maryland so I'd like to
stay local to that but I am open to the
idea of a remote role and at first I
didn't think there were a lot of remote
tech developer jobs out there but they
seem like there is a fair amount so
Maryland or remote be my preference
great and what about titles titles that
is also a good one front end developer
is probably one I've been looking at the
most sometimes I see the term a
front-end engineer which I think alludes
to maybe more having more JavaScript or
Python type knowledge so something along
those lines but I briefly I was
interested in doing like data scientist
type thing but I think I keep falling
back to like front-end developer of some
degree or web developer I guess -
awesome in are there any industries that
really interest you there's also a good
one
no real preference I I would see I would
say I keep looking at other tech
companies so I'm looking at places like
github Gatsby
you know Trello and I think um was a
buffer I think they're full of remote -
so I think I'm staying in like other
tech companies I also have rules yeah so
you're more focused on trying to find
that remote gig than any specific
industry one thing that's really
interesting about the industry and and
with all of these pieces when chatting
with
folks about their career goals it's hard
to get specific right because every time
we see a new job listing we want to jump
and and see if that's the one that we
can get and so it's like oh I want to be
a front-end developer but then I saw a
back-end thing or I saw and you know
data science something else and I got
distracted went down that road what we
want to do is start specific go deep
before we go broad so if you think about
the way most people do a job search they
say get an email from LinkedIn right it
says here's all the new jobs today and
we go down that list and go maybe this
one maybe this one maybe this one and it
kind of takes us in a scattered
horizontal view of the job search right
we're going from one unrelated job to
another so we might be like oh I'm
looking at front-end developer role at
Nike and then the next job is back-end
developer role at a bread company right
it's like it's all over the place so we
want to get focused go all the way to
the bottom so let's say front-end
developer at communication tech
companies and then we go and look at
every single communication tech company
until we get to the bottom and then we
can try the next search so maybe we
didn't find something in that vertical
we can go to the next one on the list
maybe Nike or sports and so there's just
a quick tip before we jump in here and
to help you out here is the entire list
of industry codes that companies can use
on LinkedIn to segment their you know
what industry they're in so if you're
curious you know about dairy or design
or eLearning
these are the codes that you'll want to
look up as you're doing your search and
the reason that this is interesting is
because you can start looking at what
the companies are saying what keywords
they're using and you can adjust your
profile to match because the biggest
thing about LinkedIn is that it's a
great tool for SEO if you want to be
found you have to say the right things
and so we need to know what the
companies and the industries and the job
titles that we're looking for are saying
so we can go deep alright so I'm
throwing a lot at you but let's jump
into your profile here so you had
mentioned that you know you feel like
you have some experience but
you're you're still trying to figure out
like how to how to and how to really
take more control over your profile and
make it look really great what are the
areas where you think I you know you
want to focus the most or you feel like
could be stronger on your profile I
definitely think that a blurb section
the summary the elevator pitch is where
I can where I'm definitely lacking right
now that's just some things I threw in
there like the other day and since I
haven't been keeping this up to date I
don't really know what to put in there
to speak to what I do what I would like
to do in the future so I think that's
probably like would be like the biggest
win for me is to get that summary up and
up in a good place
awesome so yeah we would definitely jump
into that and I know you had mentioned
in our in our pre call that you know you
were really hoping or you you wish you
had been keeping your profile more up to
date on a regular basis and instead of
just getting to it at the start of a job
search and I think that that's something
we can all feel out there
I think everyone wishes that they kept
their resume and their LinkedIn and
their cover letters and everything as
up-to-date as possible but usually it's
when we're in crunch time that we gotta
go so we'll dig into this but before we
do that I want to point out a couple of
great things about your profile you have
a really good headline here you say
you're a senior email developer so you
know so when someone comes to your
profile they know exactly what you're
working on and what you're capable of
you have you know your highlights and
your activity
but the main thing here is your
experience you've got all of your
experience it's all linked to the
company profiles so the images are
coming up although we got a freelance
one here and some other things that
won't necessarily pull up an image and
you've got some descriptions in all of
these things a lot of profiles don't
have descriptions we may want to work on
consistency with these bullet points
because some have bullets and some don't
but in general the fact that you have
content in here is going to help boost
your profile in the rankings and so what
we want to do is we want to kind of go
through here and either just make it all
consistent so it's easy to read and then
eventually we'll want to tailor all the
descriptions here to be more focused on
the types of keywords and jobs that you
want to be doing in the future
you've got your education here all the
way up to date and you've got some great
volunteer experience which also shows
that you're you're going out and you're
doing even more your skills section has
some great stuff in it but I have a
feeling you have more Skills than just
this so we'll want to probably revisit
that and add more skills as well and
recommendations it's awesome that you
have some great recommendations here one
thing I've heard from a handful of
recruiters is that they are not as
interested in recommendations they're
more interested in these skills here in
the descriptions and I'm realizing I'm
taking a long time on these profiles so
I'm gonna jump right back up here and
we're gonna get into your your summary
so in your summary you start by saying
hi and you talk about yourself and then
you mentioned a few of your speaking
engagements so this tells me a few
things it shows me that you're outgoing
and it shows me that you are going out
and speaking which means you have good
presence good presentation skills and
things of that sort
now one thing you want to think about
when it comes to the summary is you want
to make it very you want you want to
describe who you are but you want to
focus on the person who's reading your
profile and what their needs are so as
you think about this being a email and
front-end developer what are the
problems you're able to solve for other
people rather than saying what you've
done in the past this is your ability to
say what you hope to do in the future
for others so just take us take a second
and maybe brainstorm out loud what are
some of the problems that you're able to
solve through email and front-end
developer roles
it's a good one I think one that I run
into is sort of consistency across your
digital landscapes like if you either
theoretically if you're opening an email
from company you're clicking a link
you're going to a web page or something
like that sometimes there's a disconnect
between those experiences and sometimes
the email experience from like a design
or a content or you know mobile user
perspective is just not great at all
like some companies are great at it
others are very terrible at it so having
that insight about just what recipients
are doing or how they're viewing email I
think a lot of companies could benefit
from that that's awesome so that is a
key benefit that you're able to bring to
a company that you can call out in this
summary section so instead of saying hey
I'm this is my name and this is what I'm
experienced in you can say as an email
and front-end developer I work to help
companies build consistent visuals that
help their audience better engage and
better interact with their products my
background is with grow with Google
Udacity and here are some speaking
events where I've actually taken this
stuff into the real world and engaged
with you know so on and so forth I'm
getting a little bit marketing with it
but what do you think of that kind of
approach to your summary and and how
it's cooking in your head no I mean that
sounds good I'm taking notes as we're
talking here but you're right it's good
to say it I mean what I've done or what
I can do will come up more I guess as
they go into the later parts of my
summary but to speak to like here's what
I can do here's what I specialize and
that's probably more attention grabbing
than just what I have currently
absolutely because you might find that
folks out there like wow our brand is
really disconnected you know we've got
all these different things going on and
if you're the person that can bring it
all together make it look good and make
it engaging that's gonna be a great way
to go and you've got that design
background to back it up as well so I'm
gonna we're gonna keep moving forward
and jumping into the other profiles but
thankfully this is recorded so we can
always come back and take a look but I
do think like when when you're thinking
about your profile try to make it more
about the problems you solve and how you
can help other people and then back up
your ability to solve problems with your
experience that's the best way to
showcase what you've done in
relationship with what you can be doing
alright thank you
absolutely and we'll we'll open this up
for questions later too so I know
there's a bunch of questions coming in
but now we will jump into Dean Dean your
profile how are you feeling about it and
where do you think you want the most
focus marketing yeah I feel that
right now my profile is decent I feel I
have a lot of information there I like
to try get good feedback regarding is it
too much information
should I condensed it somehow and
summarize it or since people want to go
to look at your Linkedin typically they
don't want to give wrong information as
opposed to looking at your resume I do
have my resume linked up top as well
that maybe this mile detail happens
appropriate for people to dig in further
to learn more about myself that is a
great question Dean thanks so much
so I actually looking through your
profile you're right you do have a lot
of great information and it's consistent
you've got bullet points going through
each one you've even got media for all
of your roles which is a really big
thing that LinkedIn is allowing us to do
now linking to videos and projects and
things of that sort within each one of
our roles so when it comes to your
question is it too much that's one that
I'm sure can be debated but when it
comes to your LinkedIn profile this
isn't your resume this your resume you
want to get it down to a page because
honestly no one's gonna read more than a
few they're gonna skim it or just kind
of briefly go through the one-page but
with your Linkedin that is like you know
this is basically your your place online
for people to see everything you've done
in your career so it's okay to have a
lot of information the question is is
the information you're putting on here
relevant to what you're hoping to do in
the future as well so what you might
want to do is go back through some of
these descriptions that you may not have
looked at since you originally
put them in right and see is this still
relevant or can I update the language to
be more relevant to what I want to be
doing in the future and so let's say you
developed integrated and tested multiple
real-time human-in-the-loop Hardware in
the loop physics based aircraft
simulation systems well from our
previous conversations you know you're
still interested in the aerospace and
robotic space so this is definitely
still relevant and something that should
be kept on your profile and so I I do
think that that's a great question and
definitely one where too much
information when it comes to these
descriptions here probably isn't a big
worry it's it's ok to have too much the
main thing is make should make sure go
and look at some profiles some some job
listings and make sure the keywords that
are in the job listings you hope to have
are also included in your profile so as
you're taking a look here I just wanna
make sure we're doing good on time as
you're taking a look here you say I'm an
experienced mechanical and aerospace
engineer you support NASA and and you've
got a lot of great stuff here so you've
got some hands-on tinkering alright so I
actually think your summary is really
strong I like that you link to your
resume you might be able to break it up
a little bit so it's easier for people
to read and consume but overall I like
that you put your skills up in the
summary C++ Python and things of that
sort and I think you've got a really
great strong profile here
so as you're sort of thinking about what
you want to do next let's answer those
questions for you as well where are you
looking or what title do you want would
interest you yes I'm located in the
California San Francisco Bay Area so I'm
looking to stay locally though I'm open
attention to remote though the type of
work I'm looking at I think a lot of the
pie required need to be in person to do
system integration hardware software so
expect to be a staying local the title I
want I left on my LinkedIn profile it
kind of
vehicle autonomy engineer since I could
get into cars aircraft air ships
underwater submarine all those were
apply since hence I've kind of left a
generic if I would based on your earlier
recommendation when discussing with
Shannon if I want to get very specific
perhaps maybe a control vehicle control
and path engineer perhaps will be the
area but then you know that's one of
those things where I want everything as
well a lot of other I don't want to miss
out on the opportunity to learn about
computer vision it's about being a
fusion and such because I feel those are
all related to be an effective vehicle
Tommy engineer do you need to you know
can be too fixated on one area and then
well it's the loss of your industry so
coming from aerospace most of the things
I have most of the entity ice opponent
past has been government entities and
I'm also looking to transition from
government into private sector mmm-hmm
vehicle I'll tell me aircraft autopilot
that worked with in the past
I don't sort of a ui/ux for aircraft
cockpit your flight control integration
with human in there but yeah so even
though those sounds very much similar it
is also very different up in the area
you don't have potential kids running
out of street getting to in front of the
aircraft so the type of technical focus
are different absolutely so I think
you've got a really good view here I
think maybe one of the things that you
could put in your summary is saying you
know you have a background in more
governmental work and you're really
excited to bring these skills into the
private the private sector and so by
calling that out and saying like here's
what I've helped government do and
here's how I can help in the private
sector you might be able to make that
connection but I think the bigger thing
is to really narrow in on job titles
again you don't want to miss out but one
of the weird things about
not making a decision is that that is in
and of itself a decision so we have to
choose something put it in your profile
and this is the great thing about
LinkedIn you can update your title spend
a month looking for that title seeing if
you find anything and if you get to the
bottom of like the well with that title
and you find oh wait
I talked to seven people and this job
doesn't sound like what I want delete it
put in a new title and give that one a
shot and so you're kind of allowing
yourself to be flexible but also be
specific so that you can focus your job
search and not be scattered too much
does that make sense
yes thank you
the other question I have if you're
ready to take that back I think we need
to jump to Ellen but let's bring it back
to the questions section all right so
we'll come back to that one and just say
thank you so much Ellen how are you
doing good all right so you are
multilingual you're located in New
Zealand and your data foundations nd
grad I noticed that when I first went to
your profile the other day it was half
in English yes so it's still here I know
you have a couple different languages on
your profile here so this is something I
think is really interesting because as
we're putting together these profiles
you never really know how it's going to
show up on the other person's side now
LinkedIn allows you to say like view my
profile from another perspective so if
you actually go to your home page you'll
see that you're able to do that but also
one thing to notice about Google and any
webpage and you probably all know this
but just in case you don't you can
translate any page so that it comes up
in the way that you need it to be
however when it comes to building your
profile I want I'm curious from your
perspective have you seen what was it
like when you put your profile together
and how does it look on your end yeah
link being when I created my company I
drove the before
it's a Chinese company so the name all
Chinese I actually I don't know how to
change it to English because it will you
pick you reduce the Chinese company name
it's a Chinese version not English so I
I think I it's a nicotine problem very
well could be in I actually this is
something I'm not as well experienced
with so if it's something that anyone on
this call is experienced with please put
it in the chat and share any thoughts
you have but one thing you might want to
do is in your summary call that out say
you know I've worked with Chinese
companies in the past so I but I'm
looking to work I believe since you're
in New Zealand are you looking to work
with english-speaking companies in the
future yes okay so you might want to
call out like if you're having trouble
viewing this page right click and
translate let google translate so you
can see everything below
all right so that might be a really good
thing to call out and then another thing
here going back to our points about
LinkedIn profiles we need to get a
picture of you in here in order to
increase your visibility on LinkedIn oh
maybe I'm a second connection and it's
not showing up that could be it
but on your end you're saying you do see
it recently there are problem I found it
in ding-ding-ding tea has a few
different network when I add someone
they said you are not in director
Network so we cannot add a connector
friends or something
so maybe I'm still in China Network ok
all right it's definitely something to
look into go ahead I have patrons here
um on my end I'm not able to see it so
that's actually a really interesting
thing to call out and so if you go to
your LinkedIn profile here one thing
that you're gonna want to do is and this
is for everyone on the call you're gonna
want to say you're gonna want to go to
one of these call-outs where it lets you
view your profile they moved it on me
so I'm trying to remember where they put
it here here we go
all right so it looks like we can add
our profile in another language that
might help with your language
translation and there is a section and
I'm sorry I'm not finding right now
since a few things have moved around but
we'll want to figure out how to view our
profile so the way other people see it
so we can come back and take a look and
make sure it's showing up how we want
online that sound good
I think if you go to the top right and
click on edit public profile yeah scroll
up there should be an option this is at
a public profile all right
in her profile Oh in my profile all
right now now my pictures not coming up
all right so looks like something weird
is going on with LinkedIn right now so
oh there it is all right so this is
where you can go to well now it's not
showing up
all right so and I don't want to get us
to derailed here and maybe we follow up
after the call to make sure that we're
looking at the right stuff here but in
general what we want to do is we want to
make sure that our profile has a summary
that talks about the problems that we
solve has content on it and a title that
reflects the job that we want to have
and has a photo and all the necessary
information and is translated in the way
that we want it to be translated and if
we can't change that on the back end put
a note in the summary to say right click
and translate profile in order to view
all the date all the details below so
those are three takeaways and then I
want to jump into the next part of our
call here for anyone else who would like
some feedback on their profile so all
right we got about 126 folks still on
the call here add your name into the
chat post a link to your uark to your
LinkedIn profile and Karen will take a
look through and she will call out and
see if anyone wants to to share their
information and actually this might be
one where we merge it with the Q&A since
we are running a little short on time so
we might pull up your profile or you
might just answer your questions as they
come up so feel free to add your
questions in the chat and I've got a
bunch here that I'm going to start us
off with
all right our first question here if I'm
not working now is it better to write
that I'm self-employed so this is a big
question and something that we've seen
come up on a few different profiles
which is a lot of times when we're
searching for a job we put seeking a job
or we put open to new opportunities or
we put different things in the profile
the problem is that our headline is
actually a search tool it's not so much
what we want people to see it's what we
want people to be able to search so if
I'm online and I'm searching for a new
employee to you know do my front-end web
development I'm gonna search for
front-end web developers and if that's
not in your headline you might not show
up in my search so we don't want to put
unemployed or anything like that in that
headline or even self-employed since
that's the question should I say that
I'm self-employed you should put the in
your experience section let's say you're
working on a project right now you want
to put down whatever your business name
might be whether it's a blog page or
your github page or whatever it might be
and that's what you're currently working
on then you list out all the projects
all the education everything that you're
currently doing today so there's not a
gap there and you want to be very clear
that you know I'm developing this skill
set so you're not trying to fake it
you're not trying to say oh I have a job
when I don't
you're just saying at this time in this
window of however many months that I've
been searching for a job here is what
I'm working on and by doing that you can
actually give yourself that title which
will show up in your headline and that's
gonna be the thing that allows people to
find your profile see that you are
either working for yourself or you know
maybe it's your own personal name maybe
it's a blog you created
whatever the thing might be maybe it's a
cool project you worked on in an open
source community and that's going to be
your most recent experience that you get
to reference
all right next question here how
important our skill endorsements I
believe having all your skills listed
and we'll scroll down just to the skill
section here so I believe having a very
robust skills section where you do
include everything that is related to
the job that you want is extremely
important because this all gets crawled
for the SEO now having tons of
endorsements on each skill I don't think
that has as big of an impact as just
having the skill on your profile so one
thing that you're gonna want to do is
make sure that the the skills are here
and ranked how you want them to rank you
can actually move these around it it
doesn't it doesn't rank it by the number
of endorsements it ranks it by how you
rank it so when you go in here take a
look Andrey ranked your skills the way
that you want them to appear in your
profile
all right our next question what should
we do for the location section if we
need or want to continue working
remotely I see the options are only
based on zip code so you put that in
when it comes to your location you put
your current location or if you know
you're moving in the next six months you
can put your future location and then
what you want to do is in your summary
write open to remote work or flexible or
location flexible things of that sort
that call out that you're a remote
person and maybe even in your job title
if you're currently a remote worker put
remote in your job title that way it'll
show up in results if someone wants to
search for a remote worker but typically
people aren't searching for remote work
it's a conversation that you need to
have when you're applying for a role or
getting an offer in order to find that
remote job how do I organize my data as
per my timeline or work as per my field
or relevancy I assume this means like
should I put my education first should I
put anything else first
the key thing you want to do here is you
want to put the thing most relevant to
what you're trying to do first so if
your education let's say this is your
most relevant thing feel free to put it
above but if you've been working in a
field that's similar to what you want to
be doing in the future feel free to put
that above but I would say either
experience or education are the first
two things that should show
um what do I do when I have a gap of
seven years from my last role this is a
really big question and it's it's quite
it's quite specific to the person but if
you have seven years of a gap one of my
questions would be what did you do
during those seven years were you a
mother staying at home raising a family
were you volunteering for any causes did
you have any part-time or contract or
other type of work were you part of any
organizations is there anything we can
do to fill in that space and one of
those things will be a relatable story
so let's say you know your stay-at-home
mother raising a family there's a ton of
skills that come from that that apply to
your next job
and the other thing to think about is
that there are tons and tons of
organizations that exist for mothers to
get back into the workforce and so you
want to tap into those markets because
they aren't gonna worry so much about
that seven-year gap and they're gonna be
actually look at it as a positive
because they've seen other people with
similar backgrounds do great work so
whatever your history might be there is
a community to tap into on LinkedIn go
take a look at some of the groups and
some of the groups that are out yeah
take a look at some of the groups that
are out there and you know own what
happened don't just ignore it don't just
assume people won't ask they'll think
about it so it's good to have your
answers well practiced
you
what is the best way to showcase work
outside of job roles meaning personal
projects speaking engagements volunteer
work etc well there is a great volunteer
section on your profile so if you scroll
down you can actually see that let's see
I think Dean had a very good volunteer
section here so dumb education guys am I
going too quick I'm missing it but there
is a section for volunteer work and that
will be a good place to put in
accomplishments and things like this
another thing that's really great to do
is start a personal project so if you
have a little side project that you want
to just put all of your volunteer work
into that's a great thing to do it
actually you put that in your experience
section and you can really showcase oh
not only am i doing my normal job but
I'm also doing speaking engagements and
I'm doing you know I'm running a meet-up
let's say you can put that meetup in
your experience are in your volunteer
section either one and showcase that not
only do you do your day-to-day role but
you also are building community outside
of it or whatever it is you might be
doing
all right I know we're coming to the
last five minutes or so here so I'm
going to try and get through some more
of these questions
you
ah are there any no knows about updating
your LinkedIn profile when you are
currently employed and I and don't want
your current employer to know well there
is a great setting on everyone's profile
whenever you're making an update that
says do you want to share this with your
network so LinkedIn has done a great job
of actually making it easier for you to
control what does and doesn't get shared
I know back in the day they used to
share every little thing someone would
change on their profile and you get a
dozen notifications from people they've
done a good job cleaning up their side
and we've done a good job cleaning our
side but just make sure whenever you're
making updates your headline or
something you look at that little toggle
button and say you do or don't want to
share it if you don't want to share it
just don't share it update your profile
and companies it depends on the company
you're working for some don't care some
are always looking I would say more
don't care than are always looking but a
key thing to keep in mind is that you
want to make sure whatever you're
updating I you know it's you you should
always be updating your Linkedin it
shouldn't be every three years so if you
get confronted about it yeah I'm just
making sure things are being updated as
I go and I want to jump ahead real quick
because I got a little deep into the Q&A
here but if you are a current student a
really important thing to do is to get
your project in for review for the
deadline so we have a number of students
who are on this call and your deadlines
are as follows November 6 Google AdWords
November 10 computer vision 19th flying
car 20th artificial intelligence 25th
front end 27th deep reinforcement
learning in 28th robotics and so what
you want to do here is go to this link
and we'll send it out
and it's going to give you the option to
submit your profile so you're going to
change your visibility you're going to
get your URL you're gonna hit submit
project go to submission
all you have to do is submit your link
so let's say you don't feel very strong
about your profile profile right now and
you want to update it before you uh you
submit it I would actually encourage you
to submit it first because it's better
to get you know get it in and start
getting feedback and then you can build
on that feedback rather than trying to
get it perfect before you submit for
feedback it's it's if you have a profile
that's got content on it it's a good
thing to start getting feedback so go
here submit that link and you'll start
getting some really great feedback get
it in before your deadline because
that's a really important piece in order
to stay eligible and make sure that
you've got that all in once you do this
you'll get some really good feedback you
can see in these slides here they're
gonna break down each one of your
sections and they're gonna tell you
exactly what you need to know in order
to improve their profile so this is
going to be extremely important and just
you know it's great for us to talk about
it but it's even better for to get an
expert in your industry to look at it
with a much more focused pair of eyes
alright and then I'm going to wrap up
with a couple more questions here
I'm taking a look real quick I just
graduated from the front-end web dev
nanodegree but I have no experience in
the field how do I attract employers to
my profile if all my experiences in
different fields so the keywords used in
my job education description will be
from different fields
that's a great question this is where
your volunteer work your personal
projects your skills section and your
headline come into play you want to make
sure your headline is talking about the
job that you wish you had you want to
make sure that your experience or your
volunteer work represents all of the
projects that you've been working on on
your own time and also by talking about
those projects you'll be talking about
the keywords and different things that
these this new role is looking for you
want to make sure you update your skills
section with all the right information
and really you know in your summary say
here is how my background is going to
help inform my future so one of my
favorite phrases is I've merged a
background in this topic with a with my
recent work in this topic in order to
accomplish these things for clients so
someone recently said I merged my
newfound interest in development with a
background in management to help
companies install Salesforce CRM systems
and so that's their like boom I got my
past experience my current experience
and the thing I help companies do so
that's just a great way to think about
putting a profile together if you are
entering into a new space
all right so finally before we wrap up
today I just want to say please please
please go here if you are a current
student well go submit your profile it
takes just a couple of minutes it's a
copy of pace it's real fast and you will
be done and you won't have to think
about this anymore in the future and and
if you'd like to connect my name is
Martin McGovern I am on LinkedIn as you
can see here and I look forward to
watching all of your profiles improve
and it's being you all crush it stop
searching alright that was a lot that
we've just done in time thank you all
for joining me and joining us on this
call I will stick around for the next
five or so minutes as people wrap up if
any other questions come in maybe we can
touch on them but give yourselves a
round of applause I know everyone's
muted I hope I hope it's been good in
the chat and I've kind of got an air of
you on my own awesome wonderful thank
you all so much for joining looks like
you're all jumping off now I'll hang on
until until everyone
is logged out and I hope you're all
connecting with each other with all the
profiles that you shared